hello everybody and hello lady down
there how are you doing today
you don't look so good and welcome to
let's play cellar door okay
now this is a game that is scary
who'da thunk okay let's get into it
oh hello wait hang on picking myself off
the floor oh hi
should i I don't know if I should you
don't look so good there look kind of
ghostly I know a story the story is true
I believe it and you will too
another entity has entered this world
dark and dangerous
the evil unfurls find my marbles before
time is through and I will share my
secret with you why can't you share it
now am I responsible for you losing your
marbles do I have to lose mine to find
yours is that how this works yeah yeah
okay alright alright lady I will help
you soon I'm assuming that my icon is
gonna turn green if I come over
something that I need it's one of those
point-and-click style adventure games
where you gotta find stuff over and over
again
hello oh I found a model lady lady
little girl I found a marble how do I
get back there we go
gonna find what a click is this your
marble find all your marbles okay oh why
do I have to be in a creepy basement how
did I get here in the first place I
don't even know I don't have to try to
click on everything I like this place
I'm turning up my volume just for
maximum scare - oh I thought that was a
face ok it might still be a face you
never know with these things
can I pick this up as a weapon can i
bash in I go all I said it turned up my
volume ow
God dang it that was loud
I don't know what I I talked over to
something that opened the menu I think
idea
Jesus stop it don't do those things to
me okay um does anyone see a marble
anybody anybody see Omar but I'm playing
this on a website so that's what and
it's a flash game so that's why that
thing opened up when I went as green I
don't see anything here no I knew it was
a ghostly face I knew it was Trixie's is
there anything here about over here oh
it looks good yeah yeah real good
how much but to find some marbles in
here there's no way there's no way I'm
not gonna find any Zetas marble it's a
little a beat'em Armando no marble
marble I've lost my marbles I'm going to
die hello found another marble all right
that makes two good good for me I found
two how many do I need to find how many
will make this little girl happy yeah
damn teenage girls they don't know what
they want I don't know how old that girl
is oh good we're going out of the cellar
should be fun Xen eBay is anybody gonna
jump out at me what the hell was I just
do oh I see I went backwards okay oh can
I jump to my death that'd be fun
no Gabala I'm not gonna jump I feel like
jumping okay is there a marble up here I
don't like this game oh I get it all if
it's carried open let's see what let me
get off the ledge please thank you okay
so anybody see a marble anybody oh well
I'm not in the cellar anymore so what's
the worse can happen
thirty-two claws on the door man what
house did they get these pictures from
this is awful this is horrible
who would live here that a lock thingy I
even know where I am anymore
I'm so confused disoriented where do I
go what do I do
why am i it was a scientist was a
scientist man go away get out of here
you and your lab coat okay something up
there up there up there marble marble
marble give it okay I got three marbles
is that enough we'll just make this
little girl happy now I found three
marbles Kanna oh can I go home pretty
pretty please oh I have this way hang on
there was a something else there no yes
yes no yes haha wait a minute no this is
different
hi I got your marbles are you the same
little girl this is where I came in no
it's 22 what was that hello we're unable
to take your call right now but if you
leave out your number we'll be sure to
be in touch real soon
five five five two nine four if I Bufo
boop boop boop okay maybe that's a sort
of thing where if you put your real
phone number in there you'll give a like
a call or some on your phone I'd be be
disturbing okay so let's not do that I
need to find something with a marble
anywhere I don't think so okay let's go
down these stairs I'm not gonna jump
your stupid voices in my head get on my
head I'm not a monster
I'm not a monster
hi dude ye looking good looking real
good if you lost weight man you're
looking good anybody else down here want
to just pop in and say hi
anybody else want to join the party ha
ha ha ha ha ha another marble but I have
no idea how many I'll need God for I got
four now where can i oh I'm back in the
beginning somehow I've lived all the way
around little girl I don't have all your
marbles yet
dammit where could your where could your
mother marble possibly Oh what is this
what is this what is this Zora marble in
here I don't see one have I been in here
have I looked in here I don't know if I
have I don't remember this this is all
unfamiliar to me how am I supposed to
know Andrews I'm not dancers I'm not
good enough for this game you can't
circus this game is a tush alright let's
just keep moving ok I got marble
whoa-ho-ho ha ha
that makes 5 is it I don't have marbles
to make a full set I went down the other
pathway to get where's another one
damn it how many marbles have I missed
that's like two more in the same area
little girl you have too many damn
marbles ever thought there's got to be
one over here somewhere this just got to
be I mean if there's one that easily
over there let me just actually let me
check no I found one up there that's
where I found the other marble so let me
check with the little girl to see if
I've got enough marbles to make her
happy no wrong wrong wrong wrong wrong
is it over to the left to the right to
the right to the right
I've looked in here I've already got one
from there yeah as beautiful as your
singing is I really don't want to hear
it right now little girl so how about
you shut up
how about you should how do i damn it
it's like impossible to friggin navigate
here have to go all the way up and then
back down son of a biscuit
hello ah ha ha ha found another one I'm
like a professional at finding these
marbles I've got 7 now is 7 make a set 7
all I need maybe ok I'm on the complete
other side the phones over there
so if I go to the left oh hello what are
you a la dia report from Alma iike hen
Costas jenkin men Skylon de bellas
Garvin the Swedish Oh No 16:1 Jacques
son man if this is a real house in a
real place I feel bad for the people to
live here ok so this is way back down
what the hell is that that a bowling
ball in a bowling bag or a little
monster staring at me I don't know can I
please please find where that little
girl is where the hell nah come on you
gotta be joking me where the hell is
this damn person uh that's new why why
why a pedophile oh go oh look out oh
come on
all your marbles oh no oh that noise s
was our marble like here maybe the
eighth one is the last one and it's in
here somewhere
come on what does it ball I don't even
know how many marbles there were either
way alright I guess I'm done for now
so anyway Oh a cellar door you guys
could try for yourself oh it's Deb oh
pretty good pretty good for a flash game
so anyway try for yourself linked in the
description um how many marbles were
there let me know in the let me know in
the comments below if I missed any
though right in front of my face mock me
mercilessly in the comments like haha
you're so stupid marklar how dumb can
you be okay so say those exact words in
the comments if I missed one so thank
you all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye
Oh
Oh